freunde herzlich willkommen in miami
beach und nicht nur babys sondern in
ganz miami denn wir werden die besten
interessantesten wildesten food hotspots
ihr abdecken was ganz neues auf meinem
channel testen nicht ein ressort nicht
zwei nicht drei sondern ein bisschen
mehr heute und es wird sehr sehr weit
ist wird sehr sehr leckeres essen geben
dann schaut's aus einem tomtom die
prämie das schon häufiger gemacht hat
und ich freue mich unglaublich darauf
was wir heute erleben werden es sind
sachen die waren auf meiner food bucket
list für jahre so und heute ist es
soweit viel spaß mit dem video viel spaß
mit den eindrücken und los geht's
[Musik]
pura vida miami leute hier kann man
gesund frühstück nicht nur frühstücken
sollen den ganzen tag über schnecken
gibt es an verschiedenen orten in miami
auch in miami beach sport und das
besondere ist dass gesunde bei ihr
werdet auch in diesem video gesehen es
gibt nicht viele gesunde sachen papier
ein eiscafé und ich habe einen perfekten
exzentrisch gewichts man einfach saison
bei
käse rucola tomate und dazu gibt es
dieses special es tut mir leid für die
leute die sich eh schon daran stören
dass immer mal wieder ins englische
wandern mindestens so schön wie dieses
essen was wirklich geil aussieht diese
autos wollte wie reich erstmalig denn
wie die betreiber von bilden wolle leute
zu zweit dort wir haben sonst huracan
evo
wir sind ja schon papa gehirn und es tut
so gut was gesundes und es schmeckt
trotzdem für unfassbarkeit also not das
auf jeden fall was man ja auch sagen das
was wirklich auffällt wie sind die lok
ist hier sind die leute die schnell was
morgens zum frühstück rückt und das sind
immer die besten spots deshalb in den
kaffeebecher
frühstücks
[Musik]
das ist dort
sollen sie ohne mit 100 gramm
wir sind ja beide zloty dollar und wir
sitzen hier vor den donuts und es
wunderbar es wirklich ist auf jeden fall
wahnsinnig schön es ist nicht so super
simpel einfach drauf geklatscht sondern
es ist und check das ist das land war
das ganze eher kommt und die haben es
drauf wir haben den park in spice donner
und wir haben den majors classic und
braun bader also gracie wir den park ins
eis gefegt und leute allein auch ganz
anders aus als die donau kommen die
rutschen so auch aus der hand und so
sind einfach mal angefasst jetzt einfach
einnahmen durch gespannt was mich
erwartet die schwöre auf alles mit
riesigem abstand der krasseste dort
erwarte
dass das flott wie das ist die textur
auf einem ganz anderen level als in
deutschland oder leyen nein gott das was
anderes alter schwede eigentlich gut
dass du das nicht bei uns haben
weil sonst würde das ist das dein ende
aber so
die donots wenn meine hände so aussehen
nachdem dort gegessen hat also die
damals richtig kann ich nicht viel sagen
der cup ist auch sehr gut der mit super
gute technische kaffeemaschine kriegst
du so gut auch selten hier auf jeden
fall wartet ab zum nächsten
[Musik]
freunde dürfte wieder mäßigen tag aus
und nicht irgendwelche kurs wir haben
wir die attacken ich weiß nicht wie oft
ich diese art von tuck uns schon auf
meiner von new page paito drin gesehen
habe wirklich unendlich oft es ist
simpel dass sein tod ihr der in das
ölgeschäft wird darin knusprig gebacken
wird ganz krank bekommt darauf kommt
käse werden das stundenlange gekocht und
gezupfte rindfleisch chilis sind in der
soße alles unglaublich und das ist der
beste teil
mitten rein
und es ist einfach nur am stimmt nicht
probieren
das ist wirklich gleichzeitig sind
sieben jahren bietet das das vierte mal
dass die leute juli als das ist
unglaublich guckt euch das an dieses
rein tunken dieses flüssiger not würde
nur dafür den weg auf mich nehmen
dazu ist ja auch eine mexikanische
pineapple so süß dass ihr das gehirn ab
dann haben wir noch dieses große grüne
scharfe soße die kannst du rom über
dadurch kann
das durch sehr partys so das ist der
kann es entstand so umbauen einfach
so das muss auch nicht schön aussehen da
an dieser boards weiße
alle so gab
zunächst
ist der südamerikanische einfluss der
hier auch kulinarisch herrscht müsst ihr
euch vorstellen dass man es mehr an
einem anderen land als an der nächsten
großstadt weil amerika auch so
weitläufig ist und deshalb werde ich
jetzt auch kubanischen kaffeetrinken ihr
wisst liebe café und bar café soll was
ganz besonderes sein in einem
authentischen spot
[Musik]
also komano kubanischer café das hier
ist eine dosis für eine person das ist
wie so ein espresso cup ist sogar fast
noch weniger als normaler ist bester
trick stand wie stark das ist nicht
unnormal geil nicht gar nicht gar nicht
so stark wie sie sagt also wenn man
espresso trinkt ich habe auch er steht
dann hat das einen nicht rum aber es ist
unfassbar lecker das ist auch sehr süß
ja da ist super viel zucker drin die
übertünchen haid komplette die
bitterkeit die kräftig kite vom vom
espresso damit aber beim kaffee meine
ich dass es wirklich lecker aber es ist
durch so 15 ich habe wir alle kennen den
lightship macadamia kopie von subway und
laut eric der hier schon mal war vor
drei jahren ist das hier der vater davon
anscheinend sind das die krassesten
cookies die es gibt auf der welt ich
selbst weiß noch nicht aber ich werde
mich davon überzeugen und wir machen das
ganze auch sechs cookies 12 dollar schon
knackig eigentlich bei skate america
verhältnisse ist das vollkommen in
ordnung aber braucht es noch war marc
adam jakupi und ich probiere jetzt
die sind nicht so einfach so super soft
sondern die haben zu diesem softm haben
die noch ein brunch dazu
aber spürst du diese tiefe wenn du
deinen und so zusammengesetzt und alles
so deine zunge tunesien auf jeden fall
sehr sehr kritisch ist sehr sehr groß
sind auch die wahrscheinlich die besten
köpfe ist hier gegeben das video hatte
man auf jeden fall sehr viel spaß ab
geht's zum nächsten partie in
lotte also maiskolben mit mario limette
payen gewürzen seeland brachten ans
licht kommt und das ganze ist in so
einem hartkäse gecovert es ist wirklich
auch hier wieder ich will das schon ewig
probieren und jetzt ist es endlich
soweit das mit einer der besten spots
hier führen wir sind bei bauers takeri
ja und ich kann es nicht abwarten man
hier das erst so richtig so richtig so
mutig angegrillt so manche haben sowieso
schwarze blitz und sonst wird genau
richtig sein so wie jetzt geht so rein
wo alles auf einmal ist
das sieht sie aus
was ich nicht verstehe wie kann ich hier
so viel geisteskrank ist essen geben
dass es nicht bis zu uns schafft von mir
zu beschreiben süßer meister im palast
herum hat dazu eine limette säure note
schärfe und dazu dieser kräftige käse
frische kräuter
auch wenn du da rein weiß diese user
einfach runter läuft dieser maiskolben
ist auch perfekt auf den punkt gekocht
beziehungsweise gerät durch zu viel wie
ich verstehe nicht warum es das nicht
gibt in deutschland das ist so krank
wenn ihr sowas in deutschland sich
versteht ist bestellt müssen das populär
machen bei uns
[Musik]
wow entsprechend sicht also das laub
star meg entschließen die macht mich
fertig etwas will man dazu sagen das ist
wirklich ein perverses und dekadentes
essen 62 dollar aber ein gesamter roma
ist natürlich wahnsinnig luxuriös aber
zugleich dass einmal an die mccanns
schießend normale makkaroni sondern so
gelockte große fünf verschiedene
käsesorten unglaublich wir teilen uns
das ganze deshalb nehme ich mir ein
bisschen was von diesen weg entschieden
hier bin ich will mich den ganzen lockt
satellier wegschnappen ich gerne mal
hier angefangen und jetzt heißt das
probieren wir probieren erstmal meckern
schießt
so cremig und das ist nur amerikanisches
für mich wenn ich dekadent ist
wertvolles wie homer mit nec und schieße
mit dem absoluten durchschnitts essen
und einfach so auf also hast du scheiße
dance geil ist dann kommt zusammen ist
egal ich gehe noch mal alles ost an
der homert verwirklichen und der fällt
auseinander prozent weißwein note dass
die cremigen mac entschied
und dann jetzt hier in schicken ich
werde das auch mit den händen essen ist
mir komplett mit hanni hauptsache
ich dazu jetzt in die buttermilch wache
da drin sind normal kräuter wirklich
sehr vermisst da würde locken schießt um
drauf ich schicke noch nicht wisst ja
auch wenn ich diese gerichten noch nicht
so oft vergessen das sind ganz besonders
gute aufführung nach vorn deshalb
genießen wir das jetzt und gehen zum
nächsten
[Musik]
klatsch burger vor mir steht der klatsch
bürger und es ist einer der besten den
ich der beste bürgerladen in miami das
hat ein lob gesagt wir haben youtube
videos geschaut von einem monat auf eine
million abonnenten und er sagt dass sie
ist der beste berner den es hier gibt
und wir müssen ihnen manchmal wir sind
amerika natürlich werden wir einen guten
burger essen müssen haben wir ein
zwiebelringen da drin so schöne brauch
spannung welche soße sondern das ist
alles käse käse fondue die demo ging auf
und nahm wie bacon dann haben wir gesagt
die gibt fleischtomate vielleicht gehört
übertrug und dann durch einen perfekt
angepasst was soll ich sagen leute dass
hier sind einfach leer sie super legend
aus wirklich also es ist es durch krasse
ich habe den ganzen tag schon gegessen
aber ich krieg gerade wieder richtig
lust richtig hunger und ich gehe drei
motto wenn ein amerikanischer bürger der
nichts anderes zu essen sagt dass das
hier der beste bürger in seinem leben
ist dann muss das was heißen hochburg wo
er
probiert ihn zu vergleichen wir gerade
wie die liga die kategorie von burger
einzuordnen aber es ist seine eigene
liga es ist nicht dieses ding konfetti
crew es ist nicht diese kleine smash
brothers ist beides darf ein echter
bürger und ich bin sehr froh dass wir
mitgenommen haben
so leute wir sind ehrlich im club auch
wenn es um krieg wir sind minecraft die
schuhe und hier gibt es also demnächst
in sachen plastik mich so richtig kracht
machen mit den händen ist ich habe in
meiner pack ich habe meiner beck dies
habe jakobsmuschel
brot und fisch also zu den richtig krank
und das auf einer backe nicht als
sachlich immer sehe auch so schon wieder
sie ist einfach nicht geht bauen doch
das habe ich gesagt halt schauen wir uns
das ganze
[Musik]
familie freunde das hier ist eine
schürze und kann schulen damit man sich
nicht so sehr einsamer es ist messi was
du jetzt immer freue mich darauf ab
diese beute gesehen daran tragen
dann wäre meine assistentin wir die
schürze findet die ziehe ich mir meine
handschuhe an ich habe dir wirklich hier
bei uns würde man sagen ein nussknacker
bekommen er ist abergläubisch sagte darf
nicht krabbeln auf zu besuchen jetzt
habe ich da
so freunde machen wir das ganze mal auf
was hier für ein aroma rauskommt ist
nicht von dieser welt wir haben wirklich
verschiedenste größe das hier sind
einfach jakobsmuscheln hat diese
handschuhe angeht kein erstes nennt der
bericht dass es zu viel eifer ganze
kartoffeln die mittleren gekocht sind
dann hat maiskolben und das hier ist
natürlich der star der show
also man durch sein bein ab
leute check hier das ist arbeit hier man
muss diese klappen beiden mit kraft
auseinander brechen indem chek aviva für
riesige haben dass wir sind da schmeckt
so wohl hier wenn wir daran gehen an die
source wir haben hier das ist gar nicht
wahr dämmen treppe hey hin soße alles
gemeinsam vermischen dazu haben wir da
drin einfach hier jakob schon mein tipp
dass hier rein war auch guckt euch das
an dann
[Musik]
das auch unding dabei willst du
eigentlich gar nicht gesehen werden
werden dass er ist gewiss einfach dass
freunde ich will nicht mehr beobachtet
werden dabei ab zum einen kühlschrank
weil ich schaffen wirklich keine
weiteren spot mehr leute ich bin wie ich
bin sagt das war's für heute ich würde
auf jeden fall trotzdem sagen das war
wirklich ein erlebnis ist war eine geile
reise werden so viele meisten sachen
ihren miami entdeckt bin mir sicher wir
werden das ganze nochmals anderen
großstädten machen deshalb danke fürs zu
sehen sowas noch schlaf die welt kommt
ist da
[Musik]